hi everybody we're back uh ladies open
for the last five seasons my next guest
has played allison parker one of the
many dysfunctional but gorgeous
residents of melrose place please
welcome courtney thorne smith
[Applause]
[Music]
norman norm norm you're sick and you're
all over her like a bear rug just
sleeping no no you know but because
before during the commercial i was
saying i had a huge crush on her yeah
and then you said you did too
i said i did when you were on day by day
i had i developed this big crush on you
and this whole talk show is a scheme to
get you here i like it when she's on the
tomorrow show with tom snyder not the
tomorrow show but the later later show
he says to me in the break no i do who i
am yeah no i know from that show that's
awesome he says to me i really like her
i saw her i'm really i really think
she's great i really have a crusher and
i said where did you know you oh you saw
him noah's place he said no i was
watching tom snyder and she was on and
she was a great guest and i said wait a
minute that's the show that's opposite
our show
why weren't you watching our show pal
because i wasn't on it that night
all right now stay this is gonna this is
we have exciting stuff to talk about
you've been on this show melrose place
for five years for five years and now
you're leaving why are you leaving
um
it's just it's time
you know i mean how many times
you mean you got tired of like they
because they had your character pretty
much go insane you know go through all
these really weird allison has been
through so much i was sexually harassed
carjacked had an affair with a married
man who then tried to rape me and then
shot himself on the phone with me i was
drunk sober while getting sober though i
got to have him did he do all that stuff
on the phone with you
wait i'm curious no i was on the phone
in the office which makes it really
awkward all right okay and he was in
seattle and he shot himself
oh my god he was on the phone i know
yeah and so you finally said there's no
more that this character can do right i
can't do any more i've been married and
divorced and widowed and it's it's too
much what's going to happen in the
season finale can you give us a tip for
all those fans out there what's going to
happen i'll tell you
okay
good night everybody we had a good time
no i mean but what give us some sense of
like is it one of those because every
year they try and have a season finale
where everybody gets into a zeppelin and
blows up you know
something well now you've given it a one
it's a zeppelin it's a zeppelin all
right are you talking about melrose
no because i
you're the biggest ass i ever met
i caught you for it
no because i swear to god and when i
lived in l.a i lived in on the actual
street called melrose place there's an
actual street there's a melrose is there
really a mountain it's really amazing
okay you know this right yes that's true
so they open a restaurant called melrose
place on it and then it's right beside
my house and every time i go out there's
all these
like tourists
and these tourists
like they're always fat and they're
taking pictures
standing in front of this restaurant
yeah
[Applause]
well thanks for the help pal
uh
he'll get over it you'll see
um what what uh now i gotta ask you
about this cause we've right shut up
that makes it all right
well i wanna talk to you about something
cause this came up earlier in the show
accidentally because i didn't know what
norm was going to talk about tonight and
it's best sometimes if i don't know but
he mentioned carrot top
you are making a movie with carrot top
right i made a movie with carrot top
okay
you've made a movie with carrot top it's
it's not out yet no can you put the
picture up of carrot top again just so
we can all see him oh there it is again
yeah
all right
okay wait a minute she left melrose
place to do a movie with carrot top
that's where i'm going my friend
this begs the question now now uh why a
movie with carrot top
why a movie with character i mean no i
don't know much about carrot top you
know i i don't know much about him i'm a
little jealous because he's a red-haired
comedian and i felt like maybe you'd do
a movie with me first then move on to
carrot top then to ralph mal from happy
days
you know sort of the three there's an
order in which you do movies with the
redheads what uh what's he like first of
all
he's extraordinarily sweet nice guy he
really is and he worked very hard and he
was adorable and he works with a lot of
props and stuff too right not in the
movie oh in the movie they took his
props away they took his props away
that's a bad time to suddenly take away
everything you know about comedy
you know you've been using props now all
your life for comedy now we're gonna
take him away when you make your first
movie was he okay though with it he was
cool he was great he did a wonderful job
you have a scene where you and you you
and him embrace yeah lots of making out
oh for god's sake
nothing but making out all right it's
like nine and a half weeks but carrot
talk
we were doing
wow
i gotta check out that movie
is it called nine and a half seconds
[Applause]
like he's premature ejaculatory
you know
you know what happened
this is what happened
you know what happened he said nine and
a half seconds and i'm looking at him
cause i know there's more
and i wait and wait and i see the
glimmer in the eye and then bang
i thought you were going to but no
but uh what's the movie going to be
called
i know what it's going to be yeah what's
that
if it's got carrot top in it you know
what a good name for it'd be what's that
norm box office poison
she's in it
what about my career courtney thorne
smith the girl sitting to your left
is in the movie i'm gonna go see it
how can you scare everybody else away no
i love this girl i would see any movie
with this girl in it she's a beautiful
lady
and a talented nice talk show yes okay
as evidenced by her appearance on our
rival show
all right well there's this two-hour
season finale of melrose place there's
this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
[Applause]
we're gonna take a break now we're gonna
have collective soul in a second
courtney thorne smith we hope she's
still our friend